a New Jersey woman caught on video
apparently trying to influence police by
citing her powerful government job is
reportedly apologizing Karen Turner
abruptly resigned from the Port
Authority of New York in New Jersey last
week after the video surfaced it showed
her confronting New Jersey police
officers in a traffic stop during Easter
Adriana Diaz is here with what triggered
the outrage
Adriana good morning good morning Karen
Turner's adult daughter was riding in a
car with friends on Easter weekend when
they were pulled over for illegally
tinted windows and an obscured license
plate police discovered the cards
registration had expired and decided to
impound it
that's when Turner showed up that is my
ID and that is my busy and I'm heading
up
Karen Turner made sure the officers knew
exactly who she was when she went to
pick up her daughter and her friends she
grew increasingly agitated as the
officers refused to tell her why the car
was pulled over you may tell me when I
may take my kids and yell you may tell
me nothing because she told me nothing
came on both of you I will be talking to
the Chief of Police week and I will be
speaking for the mayor in a statement
the Port Authority of New York and New
Jersey called Turner's conduct
outrageous and indefensible and said her
resignation was appropriate the Port
Authority has been under fire in recent
years for corruption probes including a
former Chairman's bribery charges and
the 2013 Bridgegate scandal when
political appointees allegedly created a
traffic jam on the George Washington
Bridge to punish the local Democrat
mayor for not endorsing then New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie alex armed
Levitch has been reporting on the Port
Authority security issues since 2015
this is a huge issue for Greater New
York but it's also a national issue
because if you fly through JFK or if you
fly through Newark you have to deal with
the security provided by the Port
Authority police and so if you can't
rely on them and if their management at
the top is behaving as if there's no
rule of law that's a problem for you two
senior officials with the Port Authority
may take action against Karen Turner
later today
in a statement to New Jersey's Daily
voice Turner said quote I let my
emotions get the better of me and I
regret my tone toward police officers
for this I apologize however at no point
did I violate the Port Authority's code
of ethics or ask for special treatment
Noora alright Adriana thank you you know
what she's right she didn't do any of
those other things but as the kids of
today say not a good look and I love
when she said I will be talking to
so-and-so the police officer said please
ask for special treatment in so many
words but she was asking for special
treatment
something there